if you're confused by three parent
embryos you've come to the right place
this is my kitchen lab the eggs here are
somewhat larger but the principles are
the same and allows me to demonstrate
what scientists hope to do with humans
inside the egg of course of the tube
it's the egg yolk contains the nucleus
in there the thousands of genes that
make a chicken a chicken in the egg
white at the mitochondria which make
energy for the cell they to contain a
small number of genes the problem is
this egg comes from Henrietta a very
sick hen her genes and her mitochondria
are defective so she has a disease of
the mitochondria so what scientists want
to do is to separate her egg
they want to get rid of the egg white
with his defective mitochondria and they
want to keep the egg yolk with her
healthy genes are healthy nucleus they
also have a donor egg now both parts of
that a healthy there's no problem with
that egg but they also want to go
through the same process so they remove
the donated
yoke with its nucleus they put that to
one side and they keep the healthy egg
white they want that and they add to it
Henrietta's nucleus with all her genes
to make a new egg now believe me if in a
few weeks time that could turn into a
chick it would be healthy it would
contain Henrietta's genes but not a
disease